[Music]
I'm the director of the Massachusetts
spacecraft consortium and this is one of
our enjoyable events that occurs
annually to invite a Distinguished
Lecture to come up here to Cambridge and
to talk about talk about an aspect of
space research there are many other
activities of the Massachusetts Space
Grant consortium I urge you to keep up
with us by consulting the website ma SGC
which is listed on the on the back of
the program for today's events all of
these events are open to the public and
you're welcome to to participate the we
are also the host to a spring seminar
course modern space science and
engineering which meets every Wednesday
at 3 o'clock and those lectures are also
open to the public and the schedule is
on that same website and incidentally
for those students here who are
registered in the course would you at
4:30 congregate up where Professor
Hoffman and I are are sitting now and we
will go over some course business with
that I would as well as take attendance
with that I would like to turn over for
the introduction of today's
distinguished speaker the co-director
turn this over to the co-director of
Massachusetts spacecraft professor
Jeffery Hoffman who had hands-on
experience in space with one of
Professor geo Kony's key contributions
Jeff thank you as Larry young says this
this is one of the more pleasurable
events of the year when we we get to
invite distinguished speakers to share
with us some of their experience and
today's speaker is more distinguished
than most if I may say I don't want to
go through a year-by-year his entire
life history hopefully all of you and
when you came in did get a copy of the
program and there are two full pages
detailing professor G okones
contributions
I will say one or two things by way of
highlight however first of all the work
for which he received the 2002 Nobel
Prize in Physics was really involved
with the birth of a new science which is
x-ray astronomy as most people here know
astronomy for centuries was limited to
what we could see with our eyes when the
Nobel Prizes started to be awarded early
in the 20th century for almost the
entire century no Nobel Prize ever went
to an astronomer and there are numerous
urban legends as to why this is which I
won't go into but that tradition was
happily broken when Martin Weil and Tony
Hewish won the Nobel Prize for work done
in radio astronomy and now we have
another Nobel Prize for work done in
x-ray astronomy
however professor giacconi of course was
not satisfied to remain in one narrow
region of the spectrum his work as the
first director of the Space Telescope
Science Institute which managed the
Hubble Space Telescope both through thin
and through thick involved visible and
ultraviolet he went on in his work as
the director of the European Southern
Observatory to work on ground base visit
and now as president of aui he's
responsible for managing the National
Radio Astronomy Observatory so he really
has spanned the entire spectral range of
of astronomy and in fact their newest
project is the Atacama Large microwave
array so yet another region of the
spectrum with which Professor giacconi
is
is becoming acquainted and lending his
expertise it's a unique opportunity to
have somebody who has really started a
field and has turned it into one of the
most productive areas of astronomy and
[Music]
professor giacconi I'd like to ask you
to come up and share with the audience
your insights into what we've learned
about the background of x-ray astronomy
do I have no it's all working yeah okay
thank you thank you thank you Jeff it's
nice to be back here see a lot of
familiar faces old friends I spend a lot
of my career here in Boston and
Cambridge and so it's always a
homecoming what I will try to do today
is I would not try to give you a
historical correct how do I get it lower
I mean I hear I hear they
bill okay I mean I I'm hearing myself
though with echoes and so forth so what
I would try to do today is to take a
thing a problem in x-ray astronomy and
which actually happen to be discovered
the x-ray background what happened to be
discovered in the very first rocket
flights which revealed the existence of
celestial extrasolar x-ray sources and
then try to follow the progress in
understanding what this background was
till fairly recently I mean this year
last year and that allows me to go
through also the technological
development which was involved and the
progress of the field with respect to
sensitivity and resolution and so forth
so by discussing the x-ray background we
touch on a lot of topics so the first
thing is the 1960 60 62 where you know
we started looking at possibility of
doing science in space and it
particularly had to become quite clear
by then through the work for Easter so
Herbert Friedman and his group at NRL
who had used capture German v2 rockets
to put on instrumentation and study the
x-ray vision from the Sun that there was
great advantage in working in space and
the ability to look in regions of the
spectrum which would not in which a
light would not reach the earth so there
was a general interest in looking at
ultraviolet radiation gamma ray
radiation and x-ray radiation I didn't
know anything happily or about all of
this
until I met with Bruno Rossi and he
suggested he was chair of honor at the
time of space sauce board discussions
that occurred there which included many
participants but
he transmitted this information to me
and for some reason or other that that
seemed to be a very nice state for me to
do however my background was in
elementary particle physics and I detest
that loss statistics experiment my
thesis was I was up at the plateau rows
are wonderful place to ski 3,500 meters
and it took me two years to collect 80
protons in whichever studying and
interaction of protons with in lab and I
barely was able to confirm Fermi
fireballed model III thought forget it I
mean I don't want to get into another
field which is like that and that's what
you would conclude as soon as you start
studying the emission from the Sun and
you try to put it at the nearer star
that is we were talking about
sensitivities which were five orders of
magnitude or six orders of magnitude
below the kind of experiment which had
been done up to them
so I actually consider for a while
giving up and then two things happen one
is we went through a and by we now I
mean George Clark blue Rossi Burbridge
Oracle and Artie brew Rossi myself is a
brief review as physicists will do right
what is the problem what are the
expected fluxes how do I do a crucial
experiment and what we found out was
that what people had been trying to do
was not adequate because the brightest
sources we could conceive where in the
sky would give us something like 10 107
the flux of the saw point one photon per
square centimeter per second and so the
question was could you could you start
our building detectors that would be
sensitive to that kind of radiation
turned out the answer was yes but also
at the same time by chance I mean since
I'd be thinking about focusing my
protons there on the cloud chamber by
chance by reading Pflueger I came up
with a do that well I learned that he
was possible to have two
external reflection from surfaces or the
x-rays and the immediate thing as soon
as you know that and then you have had a
mother like yeah I did who is an expert
in projective geometry you come up with
a paraboloid is a concentration so right
in for the X ray flux and that was
actually done before we started you know
any real detailed history in desired
because it was important psychologically
because he told us that even if we had
to go six seven orders of magnitude
ultimately we could do it and so it
wasn't useless to start you know with
simple experiments and then a long
technological development for the x-ray
telescope and both started etc at the
same time 1960 there were an now this
was the pillar which was first
successful the payload this is the
inside the rocket shroud so imagine a
shroud around it with three windows okay
one each one two and so for them one
that you don't see
they were counters and to make it simple
in my mind I think of this triple a
changes between this instrument and what
had gone before they change number one
is the area had increased by a factor of
ten twenty I with respect to what had
been done before
then to second a antiguos it is it turns
out that the background of x-rays is
about one particle per square centimetre
per second and if you're trying to find
sources which are point one photon per
square centimeter per second then
obviously if you can eliminate the
background due to particles that will
help you by a tremendous month and the
third day which had not quite been
realized was the following if I try to
scan the sky with three arc arc three
degrees a field of view then my
probability if I launch a rocket my
probability of finding a source anywhere
in the sky with this small field of view
is about one percent so in principle I
should fly hundred rocket
to find one source I mean that doesn't
furthermore even if I find it so to
speak if I meaning if I cross it then
because I only have a small field of
view in the rocket is rotating it I will
not collect photos and so in effect you
can show that those history would never
have been able to detect scores one the
brightest or signal in the sky so when
we finally flew this instrument there
were two characteristic which then
introduced the subject that I want to
six cus in the rest one was that we were
able to see the first star so to speak
or stellar system that emitted x-rays
until that EEP revealed a background a
uniform background which we could decide
was a background due to radiation and
not to particle because we could
actually measure the spectrum by having
two counters this verdict this actually
shows the article incident without the
card or this is the counter rate which
are different windows one thicker than
the other and so you could roughly
speaking measure the spectrum of the
x-ray radiation event row so this is all
to introduce this picture which is what
we adopted was the anti cohesiveness as
I said the larger area and a very wide
field of view this field of view is
about 120 degrees so we essentially
there was no baffling there was no
attempt to reduce it and what we found
was this very strong source which I I'll
move a log that well not spend too much
time on that that's from I said and then
a uniform background all over the sky
and we concluded from we were able to
conclude from this that this was a baker
which very probably had an extra
galactic origin okay now I won't through
all of the arguments there was no
evidence of increasing as you went
through the ecliptic or when you went
through the Milky Way and so forth that
is the background which remain to be
explained for thank you I didn't know
right okay that was a background they
remained to explain and took about 40
years to explain immediately upon
finding this a contribution to to
cosmology was given because which was
interesting and negative so to speak
this background big as it was that he
was very gay because I mean there is no
trace over the cosmic component here was
absolutely much smaller than what would
one would have computed in the hot
universe model of the continuous
creation theory
so Hoyle immediately realized this and I
mean one of the things which is
fantastic here is that just because he
hadn't thought about x-rays he hadn't
predicted it otherwise he would have
predicted that the sky was going to be
awash with access but it's interesting
that just a negative statement
essentially killed that particular
theory the other question remember
historically that this is the time of
finding the three degree background
radiation then there was the measurement
of the gamma ray background from the
galactic center and somehow the idea
that the background carried information
of cosmological significance was around
let's say so in effect in 1963 when we
had this data we thought we try to think
about what the background was was all
about Burbage was the first to suggest
that this background could be due not to
a diffused emission but the combined
radiation from very distant galaxies in
which since we didn't have any angular
resolution and the flux would all be
confused together and so it dictated the
design of the x-ray telescope we
ultimately wanted I'm trying to
interweave the fact that finding
interpretation of finding and design of
the next experiment are very much
action or what you think of that that
you're doing so what I thought I was
doing is 63 I proposed at one point two
meter x-ray telescope which had the
virtue that he would could image the
x-ray background with their dung if you
was uniformly distributed with an angle
resolution 1rp lit so that we would
decide whether he was done with
individual sources or not okay so this
was the first step now we didn't do much
more than this
there wasn't any major sorry any major
change to this until in 1970 we flew a
simple x-ray satellite which if you wish
it's just a bigger counter to one it on
each side of the spacecraft the field of
view is the important thing there here
is one half of the square degree by 5
square degree then if I buy 5 field this
satellite was launched by leukemia and
since he was launched on freedom day
whoo-hoooo was called a also
because they were so much better than
the NASA SAS or ABC the year what a
whoo-hoo oh that is what we really felt
so what is the purpose of the satellite
is to do a scan of the entire sky as the
plane of the SAS days go by the plane of
the scan changes so do you have
intersection you could find the position
of sources and this was done over two
years or four years now
here is one scan and I mean this is the
score x1 the first star that we had seen
and that prevails or not the whole sky
this is in galactic coordinate here you
see now that that scale expanded and you
see how many sources we see it's over
what I want to you to do is to ignore
all the sources for a moment and here's
the background still there okay and it's
in fact the largest background the
largest contribution
of the background through the detection
of sources now the results I want to
introduce two concepts which then allow
me to to grow on the this is the result
of the catalog from the old sky search
and it's in galactic Cortina this is the
Milky Way okay and most of the sources
that you see here which are represented
by by dots of increasing size depending
on their intensity this is co x one the
most the brightest one okay galactic and
most of the other ones are almost all
our extra galactic diffused around two
fundamental findings of this of this
satellite where one the discovery of
binary x-ray system which involved the
well what sorry sorry I I inverted the
order this is the first one was the
discovery of hot intergalactic gas
what is this gasps here is a photograph
this is much taken much later not a new
horror oh this is a rosette picture they
actually and what is underneath is a I
think it's a licinia petri dish or
something
here you see galaxies there are
thousands in this cluster and here see
the distribution of x-rays which are
emitted not concentrated on each galaxy
but in the space pervading the galaxy
now that sounds you know interesting
however the most salient point is that
more 10 times more mass is in this gas a
very high temperature which cannot be
seen the visible light then is contained
in all of the galaxies that stars
represented in this picture okay so this
was finding a new state or of matter in
which very high temperature gas was a
meeting x-rays by thermogram stralla
and as we
go along you will see why I wanted to
mention this the next thing and this I I
won't go through this the next thing was
the discovery of this binary system
containing a neutron star or a black
hole and the reason why I'm bringing
this up that this was not any particular
was an extreme was that we discovered
binary system a normal stay a collapsed
are a normal star gas would fall from
the normal star or to the collapsed are
and it the collapsed are was emitting
pulsations now the question that arose
was at this position emitted at the
expense of the rotational energy of the
compact star as it's the case for pulses
and the answer is no in fact this x-ray
source is not slowing down in its rate
of rotation is acquiring energy it is
acquiring energy because of the info of
gas onto its surface and this mechanism
which is shown here if you wish in a
diagrammatical way this is gravitational
equipotential gas from the normal star
falls in the deep potential well of a
neutral star for instance and acquires
more energy per proton that you can
obtain by nuclear fusion so this is a
very powerful energy mechanism and it's
now been extended and in inner or it was
should you know as a result of who
stopped this or not this was one of the
sources which is periodic which I
mention now other sources show nothing
and then there are very erratic sources
and by bringing to the attention of the
astronomical probability this unusual
behavior then very good position were
obtained some from the MIT group some
from from itself MIT group using rockets
and then an optical amplification was
bathed by Webster Merlin he determined
that the mass was 10 solar masses six
solar masses
they are there are very rapid variation
which involved the whole star therefore
the object and they're very rapid
because these are you know at the level
of milliseconds therefore the object
must be very small and it's very massive
and it had been shown by roads and
Ruffini that no neutral star could have
a mass greater than three solar masses
and therefore this was by definition a
black hole
and what it means is we simply don't
know any physical law that prevents this
star from indefinitely collapsing now
the point that I am trying to make here
is that without going into all of this
that there was a new source of energy
due to gravity shuri info which is very
efficient and the model for what is
happening actually in the nucleus of
arctic galaxies and quasars which
explains why the tremendous amount of
energy which is emitted by this object
these two facts that is the idea that
very energetic emission in x-rays comes
from the nuclei of article actually
nuclei and is powered by gravitational
info is gives you one potential
explanation of the x-ray Becker the
possibility that hot gas diffused
throughout the universe it gives you
another potential interpretation the
difference between the two is the one
would be a diffused continuous emission
and the other one would be a point
source emission okay so there were some
now again coming back to her there was
here is the background as you see is
dominating I mean here is the cosmic
rays and this is this very strong this
is very different than what you see in
the visible light sky right it's not
like extra galactic component or the
visible light sky dominates the sky I
mean that would be that it's light all
the time so to speak but it isn't but in
actuality so
then there was a finding which you know
I thought was very suggestive if you
take the sources which are a low
Galactic latitude and you plot how many
of them as you go weaker and weaker
fainter and fainter you find the certain
point you stop increasing the number
because you're running out of galaxies
if on the other hand you are you do this
for excel galactic sources their number
keeps increasing as you go to fainter
and fainter magnitude as if the cosmic
expansion we're balanced by evolutionary
increases now this actually was done by
I see very by Matias key who was I mean
I was a real 60 kid having motorcycle
wallpaper but there was a dystrophin
finding okay so here one could be led to
the conclusion then okay so if the
external sources keep going up and up
and up then we have the experience of a
background right and in fact this was
suggested naturally by vulture and set
II know if all if all sources
extragalactic we meet at like a quasar
then we would explain the background and
here again I'll jump this away now the
other question was well what was the
spectrum of a mission or the background
and that was it looked somewhat simple
this is a composition bug or reasonably
of you know division from different
sources and he was clear that you could
explain it either with the term a branch
solid spectra which is shown here or by
- power loss spectrum and this about was
about what we do now the next piece of
important information or the seemed
extremely important at the time was this
that is this is now 1978 who was 1970
this is 1978 here one flies it's a very
large counter and it finds the spectrum
over the background and here are
different fits and as you see it fits
perfectly a terma brush a low spectrum
at 40 kilos and this became ingrained in
everybody's mind and therefore there was
the conclusion well this had to be turbo
gram column from a hot gas filling the
whole university now it never mind that
this side shall require more gas than
the total mass of the universe I mean
this was and that if it existed you
would have to explain how after cooling
it at 3 degrees which is what we see in
the microwave Baker
then you were able to reheat it at 40
kilovolts okay which were a little
problems but never mind
so this was okay and I think that beyond
that I stopped going with the known
imaging experiments not using the
telescope because there was no more
progress there was possible and here I
just wanted to show you why x-ray
telescopes can be important for x-ray
astronomy here is the absorption in the
atmosphere okay so if you go up you see
more right because this is absorption at
I think 1/2 here one hundred one tenth
what happens over here is a spectrum of
a potential x-ray source and I think was
calm colleague there who pointed out
that in normal high energy sources the
number of photo decreases as the energy
goes up it's an empirical law if you
wish but it worked and here is the limit
in which you can reflect with total
external reflection x-ray efficiently at
about a kilowatt or up to ten kilo and
here is the window of detectors
that we can build I mean it's difficult
to have detectors which go to software
softer wavelength so in this particular
the reason why x-ray telescopes are
useful is because they work here a
Maximizer in a region in which you have
the maxima statistical number of photons
coming in from a source okay now why
wasn't this clear because he was it took
a long taking a development to come up
with telescopes and okay this was a 1961
I mean statement or what a telescope
would look like you need a double
reflection to make an image this had
been done by falter in the in 1952 or
something because they he wanted to
build the microscopes he ultimately
never could build them because they were
so small he couldn't actually do this
but for telescope where you are talking
about large surfaces then you could
polish this inside surfaces to very high
accuracy and the trick was that you have
to have extremely good surface polished
much better than what you normally need
for optical status come down to three
four angstrom of surface roughness this
was hard it took many years
li'l telescopes okay replica telescopes
made of boundaries this was the first
serious telescope I think a for solar
research and which already had some of
the features that would be necessary for
stellar research but you need more area
so you make many surfaces one inside the
other this particular telescope flew on
Skylab the mini Space Station 1973 and
took a picture of the Sun and I used
this to show you yes at the technical
progress but also the fact that it's
amazing that just this picture tells you
the very important role of magnetic
fields in the containment of the hot gas
and in the production of layers okay so
it that revolutionized solar x-ray
astronomy and
actually the study of the corona this
was by jana and vance be broke now
here's the first application or attempt
to use an x-ray telescope for stellar
astronomy surfaces had to be much better
polished more area here was the interest
of doing many things four groups were in
awe of God MIT America science or
engineering Harvard and Columbia
spectrometers were put here and you
could turn for this lazy susan and have
a solid-state spectrometer imaging
proportional counters for capillaries
the spectrum etc I will just focus
because you know as a monomaniac I was
still trying to find the source of the
background so what I did was to choose a
region of the sky
where no x-ray source was known and we
pointed to this for 10 days immediate
seconds and this is mostly background
there are three sources here one two
three and then to give you an idea what
we are dealing with they fade the
sources that we were see was something
like ten eleven counts so was a one
count one photon a day that we would
collect there is a hole so the limit at
which we are going with Chandra exactly
one photon per day but now too much
fainter sources okay but it's x-ray
astronomy is not easy is what I'm trying
to say here was the same field
unfortunately I should reverse it but
those three objects are identifying now
with stellar looking object two of those
are quizzers one of them is a star
enormous star so one can draw the
conclusion and here I'm going to the
very early whoo-hoooo data and then you
see this where they the galactic star
extra lucky staffs go it's one and the
deep surly goes number two all the three
orders of magnitude insensitivity and
yet this trend of the increase in
sources as you go faith their faith that
continues now
the problem with all of this is that
these measurements are made in a
specific region of the spectrum one two
three kilowatt and so they're succeeded
long debate because of what was the
spectral content of this radiation and
whether this was just a fluke where we
may measure the background they really
was on the background the one would like
to understand now that was very
difficult to to deal with because at the
time we just couldn't go to higher
energy despair today the mirrors were
not good enough at all
now however there were some interesting
points and this was one of the attempts
we made to put some rationality in this
research the what we found was that
spectra of the so they claimed for the
proponents of a discrete source origin
for the background basically were saying
that acting galactic nuclei c4 galaxies
quasars c4 - etc would make up the
background for the few sources for which
the spot cannot be measured
spectra indexes which were very steep
that is much more low energy than high
energy stuff were found and it was very
difficult to explain therefore how the
background that looked much harder than
than what is each individual sources
that could be generated without assuming
evolution or change in the spectrum so
what we tried to show was a simple kind
of reasoning above serda which I think
had to come from a Jesuit education or
certificate honor which was like this if
you assume that 50% of the sources are
due or or 70% depending
what you like to do I do to this
individual sources that we have measured
whose spectrum we measure then the
spectrum that is left has to be very
hard right because we are taking a
spectrum which is soft spectrum that is
left is very hard now what is the could
be spectrum be a terma bremsstrahlung
spectrum the answer is no there is no
way you can reproduce the slope of the
spectrum with thermogram stralla from a
optically thin gas so in order to
explain by diffuse emission what this
are the the residual background is due
to you have to imagine that you have gas
yes but that you have to have absorption
in the gas such as the low energy of
suppressed and you allow high energy to
come through now in order to do that you
need boards of gas of a certain optical
depth and once you and you can do it one
or two ways either you have enormous
balls or gas with very low density or
small balls of gas with high density so
what we said well how do we decide
between this well we decided on two
grounds one day we wanted to have
another optical depth to get the
absorption effects we wanted and second
that the total number the total mass
contained in all of these balls of gas
which had to be millions because we were
seeing the background to be very or
materials ah could not exceed the mass
of the universe which seemed a
reasonable constraint well if you put
that constrain that immediately
collapses says that all of these balls
of gas that you're talking about that
should feel the universe uniformly have
to collapse down to 100 kiloparsec so
that means there would be the size of
our galaxy and therefore it it it shows
above tsardom that these postulated
sources of the continuous maker actually
have to be poor sources now this was not
this was a paper I think one of the
better papers I ever but actually
wasn't understood at all ie ferry said
well why don't you talk about a physical
characteristic of these objects you are
describing and I try to explain but I
anybody interested so in any case I
claimed that by 1987 the probe of the
background which was so that is we knew
it had to be due to discrete sources
however we had to prove it and we had to
show that the spectrum itself so now and
I won't there was a flight of a German
satellite York in Trumper beltro SOT we
went with deep surveys I was fortunate
enough to be involved I mean this was
they the group and we found 70 to 80
percent now the back row again remember
at low energy the spectrum of the
sources the etcetera etcetera etcetera
and still and the composition what were
the sources each one identified 39 a GN
one galaxy three galaxies group three
stars for unidentified object still
there was this problem of the spectral
and so finally it is only got sold with
the advent of AXA which only happened to
be launched in 19th in the year 2000 now
aexif has the angular solution this is
not that I will discuss pulsar emissions
but it has the angle resolution to give
you this direct picture this is no
artist conception this is the picture of
the Crab Nebula Troy the shockwaves and
so far there is a movie of it but I am
technically challenged even there
showing it to you and at this I just
wanted you to understand the power of
the instrument this is as good a picture
as you can take with Hubble essentially
of the carbon earlier in visible light
so naturally I didn't take that picture
my time I devoted for looking at the
region of the sky where no source was
known before and I went for air I asked
for a bill your second I gotta be there
cycle and here now is the field of view
or the CCD which
looked at this region and we are finding
a source density which is really
enormous with respect to what we were
finding before because there is
something like 300 sources containing a
tenth of a square degree so this is a is
it's not as high as the sorcery we seen
Hubbell because we are there we are
looking at galaxies but basically 90% of
the sources are black holes are emitting
energy by the mechanism which I was
explained to you before info from an
accretion disk onto a supermassive black
hole and the rest are interesting in
their own right this is an attempt to
show in the color I won't go through
this here is a summary of where we are
now in sensitivity so this was my chance
to show you that we went from petal 107
to 10 217 or several times 10 to the
minus 70 and this was in 40 years HM not
bad it's equivalent to going from the
naked eye to Keck or VLT so it's it's
okay they feel this mode now here is the
contribution of those sources now you
can sum all of those sources okay some
older sources and this is big arrows and
this is the termination of the
background so you see that one of the
problems saying how much of the
background is due to individual sources
we don't know really we don't have very
good measurement of the background and
but okay there could be some diffused
background still there and that will be
very interesting if one could actually
prove that that it exists now the next
thing which was interesting is remember
we are say having very few photos so
when we talk about spectra we have to
sum so this is the sound spectrum of all
of the sources with with something of
the instrument signature and then affect
to the background spectrum and as you
see it's essentially reproduces the
background spectra completely now this
is reckoned room right because when we
measure a few sources they seem to be
different now we are measuring them all
and the
fit so something is happening and here
is the different increases by the number
of sources and we can go now to take
kilovolt okay which is kind of nice so
that we don't have this problem that we
don't see the high energy sources and
you see here that at the low energy
there so damn account of sources seems
to be turning over here and here and at
the high energy five to ten kilo volt it
seems to keep going and it is going
faster than in the other spectral region
here is another attempt to show is an
attempt I mean to show why what is
happening here so but and each one is a
source we don't have enough to measure
the spectrum precisely so we do take it
what we call a hardness ratio hardware
sort of a soft ratio and what you are
seeing is that you go filter and filter
here the hardness ratio increases so
what it is is that the sources are
changing their spectrum or you are
picking up different sources than what
you were picking up when you were
looking at this we can i when you were
looking at bright words and here for is
the same trend the spectral slope which
is given by this gamma is going down as
you go to lower and lower fluxes so the
spectrum is becoming harder and now the
next step okay what are the sources so
this is the over impose Chandra as your
technical tools in x-rays on the Hubble
ACS large camera deep survey or the same
field and what you see is two points one
is that it's really important to have a
very high under resolution look at this
foresters amino and the very high angle
solution of both Chandra and of
to identify sources now once you have
identified the sources then you can go
to spectral measurements and there it's
important to have even larger telescopes
than Hubble so much of what I'm going to
discuss now has been done with Hubble
Chandra and the VLT which is the
European Southern Observatory for in
meters telescope is the largest
aggregation of telescopes in the world
so what do we find
okay the first thing we find is that
okay this was simply said the hardness
ratio seems to go has a dependence on
the brightest intrinsic brightness of
the source if you measure redshift you
can get interesting brightness these
object which are star are quizzes type
to which ad which one had been known
before so they are objects which in
which presumably you're looking at them
face in I mean without the absorbing
effect of the of the gas of their own
galaxy increasing absorption of the
galaxies these are the heart so these
are and these are the harder deserve
software sources because you are seeing
them like this these are the harder
sources because you see them through the
gas of the galaxy and they tend to be
somewhat of lower vicinity three
cigarettes ility here are sources which
are very very soft minus one and they're
galaxies okay so what we are seeing here
is c41 c42 type
active galactic nucleus but they are all
article active nuclear and here we are
seeing possibly some clusters and here
we are seeing galaxies okay let's go on
one more minute the ratio between
visible light here in magnitudes are
magnitudes and x-rays
is more or less what that we found
before these lines 11.1 were found even
with Rosa here are the galaxies again
okay here are those objects that are was
telling you that are soft and here are
the hard ones and here are objects which
are seen in x-rays even very bright
x-rays but are not seen in visible light
down to 28th magnitude and I can assure
you that observing object 28 minus 2
becomes challenging not only for
ground-based telescope that for Hubble
so we are being able to basically the
reason why you see the sources
identified up to here is because it
really is an eight meter telescope or 10
meter telescope to measure the spectrum
and you can try morphological
identification etc etc but basically
what I'm trying to say is that the
x-rays have allowed us to look at
objects whose nature we do not yet know
we need a bigger tell a visible light
telescope or possibly I'll mine the
millimeter wave to actually identify
these objects the next thing was okay so
what I'm trying to say the closing
remarks of this talk over long I'm sure
is the following that the problem of the
origin of this patterns gone away
obviously it was a known problem it was
a fiction of the theoretician for a
minute we just needed anger resolution
to in powerful instruments to solve but
what has happened here is that now
actually I want to go back here once now
the the what we are engaged in here we
go is we are broken through this fog we
are seeing the individual object and now
we study them so the first thing we did
for it I mean I there is why when Dec I
wanted to pick up this group which is
galaxies and the first thing we were
able to do is to measure the rate of
star formation in x-rays of in
a fairly large distances from us and
it's an interesting problem it was
compared to the to the node or measured
star formation rates in other wavelength
it there's now a few degrees but this is
the star formation rates or binaries it
turns out here another aspect of the
result is that when you distribute these
sources in redshift bins
you see these clumps which are have been
seen in visible light these are clumps
which are observed in x-rays which means
these are active galactic nuclei they
are not clumps or galaxies they're
clumps of Arctic galaxies or black also
call it what superb breakfasts and
finally the study of clusters in the
emission of clusters the largest you
know assembly of matter that discrete
matter in the universe this is a picture
taken into one of these very deep fields
of a very faint cluster and this was
done not only by us but also by the
people Bauer and Niels Bryant and so
forth who have been doing the same this
is our work and this is their work but
basically we have extended the region in
which we see clusters by you know
several orders of magnitude again a
little bigger to the theoreticians which
have been a pest in my life we had a
wonderful experiment which we had
proposed which was turned down not only
by NASA but by ISA and my Italian
position on the ground the no cluster
existed at this early epoch in the
universe I mean like now I could kill
but okay but that's that's that's a job
now finally something that we have found
out just a couple of months ago was ok
now we have all of the sources do they
vary if they are accretion discs
providing matter on a supermassive black
hole then
this amount of matter changes in time
then you should see changes in the
emission of the x-rays and what we find
is we find variability now again this
was done in in a very stupid way that is
we plotted out the actual intensity that
we would measure in the different
observation types and we found out that
there was a difference from one of the
vision time to the other now why are two
other groups I tried to do that and did
to succeed because they were applying
overall algorithms that would measure
this and that and so forth very
sophisticated if a software but not a
simple-minded revealing is this very
simple kind of approach so and say
sometimes you know you're too smart for
your own good here we did find sources
which are variable and the most here the
plot I mean I'm showing you very little
but the plot has to do with hardness
ratio so it says that the ones which are
most vulnerable are the one which are
the lowest hardness ratio which has to
do with the type 1 and type 2 that is
again you are not seeing absorption in
the line of sight because in in the c4
types - you have - a scattering and
therefore you have dilation of time and
this is the ratio what happens that this
is very strong and again the next slide
shows this done now as a function of
redshift variable and on variable and it
shows that the most variable one are the
one in which increasing absorption is
lowest which means that the hardest
ratio is lowest okay so this is just a
repetition of that set so to conclude I
think that I can say well we have solved
the problem background I think there may
be mother there may be an
experiment to find out is there really a
new some diffuser component second we
find many of these type of sources
clusters agents galaxies and then 10%
are identified which I am ma you know we
are convinced that it may be something
new that we haven't understood yet
but we will need more powerful optical
and now radio telescope and so forth to
see it I hope to see it within my
lifetime I mean I've been waiting for
years seems reason okay
very high source density the possibility
to study okay one third of the sources
are receipts just like it happens orna
galaxies distribution and basically what
the background s turn to is this is the
deep study of evolution of galaxies or
veggie ends and large structure well
I'll stop you thank you
[Applause]
not bad for questions first of all I
want to mention kind of an underlying
theme in the series of lectures we give
in this modern space science and
engineering seminar series is that there
are fascinating scientific questions
which can only be answered with recourse
to space observations and in doing this
we have to solve a lot of very
sophisticated and fascinating
engineering challenges and Ricardo I
think your talk has Illustrated this
perfectly fascinating scientific
questions and you've also taken well I
would like to say we need a little
another factor of maybe a hundred to
make a real difference so they're being
well I mean it's you know it's three
magnitudes in less known also I think
that it's important that we maintain
this I mean a thing that makes me
happiest is in this last experiment I
was able to use Chandra which I proposed
together with Tannenbaum and 1976 Herman
ISM and then Hubble that I was involved
in directing and then BRT which I was
involved in building so it's to me they
are all part of the Arsenal ok it's very
important that we keep this capability
in in in balance I personally feel that
the millimeter wave interferometry array
which will not which will come in
in being in two or seven to eight the
first manifestation is it's going to be
a very powerful tool here to carry out
this research I think it's important
that we go on in excess because every
time we turn around we get new
discoveries I mean we we absolutely did
not know that there was this kind of
spectral revolution in Aegean Sea we
still it's not clear I mean what no
model we had of the x-ray background
actually explained the data that we have
see have you saw that and and so we need
more area unfortunately that has to be
coupled to high angular resolution
because I mean you already saw for
instance there is that the Chandra
spacecraft is more sensitive than the
xmm spacecraft of the Europeans even
though xmm is larger because xmm gets
confused limited so if you look into a
nearby source where you don't care about
confusion limit there you can get a lot
of photos you measure spectrum memoria
but if you're really looking to very
distant sources then you really need
angular resolution to know what you're
doing
so I'm going to solution spectral
resolution an area that's what we need
the seminar at 4:30 of course you can
generate it in your equipment we didn't
generated in a phone away from cosmic
rays yeah and both those problems were
overcome well they're relatively
straightforward where they did they
require clever engineering what well the
the cosmic ray is we really don't have
very effective on the coincidence
against cause we already right now but
the cells of the CCDs are so smaller
twenty by twenty microns right that the
rate of kasra is very low and also the
DDX which you see is different i mean
the the position of energy comes in a
slightly different way so you can try
poor shape discrimination which is being
used and also seeing if you have more
than one pixel line involved and so but
it's rough I mean and that's now it's we
still are signal limited which is an
important point so that as we go hundred
times and we have the adequate
resolution we are going to go to a
hundred times each sensitivity that's a
big advantage of a telescope with
respect to simply counter right because
a counter you just increase the CCD well
square root or the area but you know to
have at the sensitivity of Chandra would
they required a mile by a mile I mean
but so and I don't think you could have
done it so that's that was a problem the
other one you mentioned was all that
then again we used pole shape
discriminate
oh no haru they were to counter side by
side so you okay
I mean yes but what not it wasn't a
physics problem I mean it's not like you
know tried to invent an accelerator no I
was okay and I think I expressed the
view of much of a community role that it
would be nice that if we if they could
be assured or continued operation of
Space Telescope at the moment we have
absolutely nothing with that kind of
refinement forest desert to look at
morphology or some of these object which
we are doing now or to to make the
statement that there is no object
corresponding to this one you have to
have extreme precision of position and
sensitivity okay on the other hand you
know there you know the well-known
discussion it is a general problem with
NASA that they started discipline but
they don't support it in a steady state
they find it very difficult to support a
steady-state operation of anything so
for instance this problem will occur
with with Chandra and x-ray astronomy
unless we do something about it as soon
as Chandra chud a case cannot be
serviced because it's too far elliptical
orbit so as soon as that dies then my
estimate this takes 40 years I'm intent
to sell and tend to build and right it
takes 20 years then you know my my so
it's going to be tough and I think that
the only thing that sustains us really
is that altogether astronomy is a
tremendous progress right and if you
become a frequency agile so to speak
you know to me this happened I gone from
high energy right to low energy as I
became older and all that so now I'm in
radio I mean I can't but anyway the
problem is what should be driving you is
the problem that you wish to solve and
you can solve it in a variety of ways
and you have to be really agile in the
sense that if you wish to use
observational materials you've got to
use the observer Styria that either you
can produce by building an instrument
that is within your means or you get it
from the virtual national observatory
from the data bank of Hubble I mean half
the research available right now is done
on a color search not direct observation
and this is unfortunately a prevalent
threat unfortunately because it creates
a generation of astronomers who never
had to build anything they just have to
analyze data and the question is who's
going to build the next you know and
it's a real issue about training and
passing on a culture but that's that's
as it is so I don't know I answer you
with too long I mean now yes
for taking the time to come talk to us
you have a significant prize
[Music]
[Applause]